Republican Senator John Kennedy of
Louisiana is known for his sharp
questions and his colorful quips but
he's also made a name for himself in the
classroom as mr. Kennedy
the senator occasionally teaches at a
school in his home state allows him to
interact with the younger generation
that's often disillusioned by politics
we followed him in the classroom for a
day and got his students reaction to
their teacher on a normal day at this
visual and performing arts Middle School
in East Baton Rouge students hustled
from theater to dance but upstairs in
the eighth-grade hallway right here an
unlikely teacher United States Senator
John Kennedy came to teach students how
government works from the basics to the
backbone of the American system even
challenging students on issues of
individual rights why should you have to
wear uniforms that's freedom of
expression isn't it outside the
classroom Kennedy said more than a
decade of substitute teaching has taught
him not every child is lucky enough to
go to a school like McKinley I remember
one little girl wrote I wish my daddy
would stop coming over to the house and
taking Mama's money and hitting her
that's what you're facing that's what
kids are facing that's what teachers are
facing but on the other hand you have
you have classes like this these kids
were were whip-smart and 90 minutes in
half the class on one of your questions
and still raise their hand oh yeah you
weren't ready to go this is how it ought
to be it's not as a country we can't
teach kids how to read and write when we
got 18 years to do it that's a disgrace
for the most part I think teachers do a
great job but they take the kids as they
find them and it's it's a hell of a lot
harder to be a kid Kennedy also
surpassed the expectations of eighth
graders Sophia Shafer Dylan harms
Malaysia Moses and trae Elston Sophia
dad was it what you would expect from a
senator it was not he
really good at it beyond the lesson plan
Kennedy made these kids feel a bit
better about politics today do you feel
like there's a lot of controversy and in
politics right now yes I do feel like
it's a lot because many people have
different opinions and to me politics is
opinions just different point of views
just because somebody has one opinion
doesn't mean that they can't be your
friends and that they're not nice people
and that's what we learned today with
this talk with Senator Kennedy he's a
really nice guy
for Malaysia politics is a passion is
your feeling like yeah this is all you
know working the way it's supposed to
the way we talk about it in school no
not at all our president is using a lot
of racist rhetoric rhetoric as if he's
trying to scare a part of America and it
does scare me sometimes it's definitely
not normal but I think that we've
accepted it as normal but you are still
really interested in and want to be
involved in it right that's probably why
I want to be involved in it because of
how much it's affected me and how I feel
every day really so that's why sometimes
I feel like I want to make a difference
in politics she was taking emotional
impressions from the president which
make her scared about her country
shouldn't school children not be scared
by their president I don't think anybody
in America ought to be scared after
school let out we sat down with the
senator in the Louisiana State Capitol
clearly the president disses ways made
he grows anxious when he has an
unexpressed thought he likes to think
out loud and I have suggested to him
before that if you're tweeting a little
bit less will not cause brain damage but
he that's it he's gonna do what he's
gonna do but doesn't he have to meet a
higher standard because of who he is
well of course the President of the
United States has to meet a high
standard but I guess what I'm saying is
he thinks she's meeting it and I
understand the president makes people
angry but it's an academic discussion
it's some problem not gonna solve it's
an issue we're not going to agree on so
let's go to work and try to do something
for the American people in the classroom
Kennedy talked about a system
constrained by its founders the federal
government only had
power given it by the Constitution but
after nearly two years in the Senate he
admits reality is different there's some
jerks there's some big egos or a few
that think they're one of the founding
fathers in both parties in both parties
so Mike I said well I can't vote on that
okay take a vote on that why are you
here grow some guts
you know people can get mad at you but
they can teach in they can't kill you
it's those kinds of turns of phrase that
have made Kennedy a popular interview on
Capitol Hill buddy up here has politics
in his blood and stuffs the reason the
aliens won't talk to us but underneath
the jokes Kennedy has hoped the next
Congress can come together on issues
like infrastructure and government
spending everybody wants to go to heaven
nobody's quite ready to make the trip
and that's the way it is with the budget
but I do have American people look at
this they say how did some of you people
make it through the birth canal
you taught a class today in civics how
different is that then what you practice
as a senator it's more theoretical in
some cases more fun and and you will
learn more in one day of doing that then
you will learn in a hundred hours of
committee testimony at McKinley
Kennedy's students hope their senator
takes a lesson on good citizenship back
to Washington I think we should all
remember that we're all human beings we
all have feelings maybe we should stop
shouting at each other and maybe you
know talk to each other I think being a
citizen means that you want the best for
your country hope the people that don't
have as many advantages as as you have
and I think basically being a citizen
needs to be a brother/sister to your
neighbor I think those kids need to go
to Washington Malaysia and Sophie and
Dylan yeah the kids were amazing Oliver
I mean they were they were 90 minute
class and they were chomping at the last
question and when they talked about
things in class you see how we don't
talk about them in Washington which is
the senator would say that's a good
viewpoint you know and somebody else
would say something and
it was all based on the same kind of
fights we have in Washington they just
weren't prejudging the people who had
the answer I can't get enough of Senator
Kennedy I'd like to sit he's a great
John thank you really great